For this style we will organize the components into layers.
For the higher level components register their interest in lower level events
and are then called back when the events occur.
In particular, the upper level components don't know the identity of
the lower level components providing the events.
The lower layers are going to handle the external events
propagating status changes upward.
So when the user moves the handle, that particular event ultimately has to
be handled so that the user sees something different.
So the event has to be propagated to higher layers into the architecture.
Which then handle it to, to affect all those indirect
indirect implications of, of the requirements of the system.
Well, I should say that the upper layers receive these notifications and
they prepare and present the results.
This propagation of events is implicit, so we call it implicit invocation.
Event announcement is made without the source component knowing the recipient
which is, which reduces the coupling between all the components.